the 70th annual Primetime Emmy Awards
were held September 17th 2018 in Los
Angeles and like all award ceremonies
they were a wild mix of good and bad
depending on where you were and who you
were rooting for relive the night with
our picks for the 5 best and 5 worst
moments from the show best Henry Winkler
strikes gold Henry Winkler known best as
Fonzie from Happy Days seems to be a
genuinely nice guy who deserves all his
success so it was great to see Winkler's
talents shine again in a big way on the
HBO hit berry and it was even better to
see him finally take home an Emmy Award
for acting after five previous
nominations
according to Winkler he wrote his
acceptance speech when he was first
nominated in 1976 which became
hilariously obvious when he gave a
shout-out to his now adult children Jed
Zoe and max you could go to bed now
daddy won worst banter isn't always
better
this year's Emmys opened with a
tongue-in-cheek song about how Hollywood
has finally solved its diversity problem
complete with the hilarious talents of a
diverse set of stars
[Music]
the funny statement-making opening
showed promise for an exciting evening
that is until host Colin Jost and
Michael che took the stage the goofy
musical act proved to be a hard act to
follow for the SNL Weekend Update hosts
who seemed a little too stiff
perhaps the hosts fell out of place when
plucked from behind the news desk or
maybe their joke seemed a bit too eager
to get a rise out of the audience
whatever the case this was an opening
that just never quite landed that's
incredible best
all hail Betty White one of the most
joyous moments of the night happened
when Kate McKinnon and Alec Baldwin took
the stage to introduce a woman who needs
no introduction Betty White the audience
went wild when white appeared giving her
a lengthy standing ovation as she gave
brief remarks cracked a couple of jokes
and seemed genuinely in awe of the
welcome she was met with no awards were
given but it was nice to have a moment
of well-deserved recognition for
everyone's favorite golden girl
[Applause]
[Music]
worst the Emmy history bits to further
emphasize the seven decades of Emmys
history a and just called up Fred
Armisen and Maya Rudolph to act as Emmy
history correspondents throughout the
show this had the potential to be an
extremely funny recurring bit
considering the gag was that Armisen and
Rudolph apparently didn't do any
research for the gig you guys know
everything there is to know about the
Emmys okay unfortunately the comedic
talents of these to SNL veterans were
wasted on seemingly pointless bits that
were made even more awkward by che and
Jos lack of enthusiasm once again out of
time best Teddy Perkins's appearance
fans of Donald Glover's Atlanta were
delighted during the Emmys broadcast
when Teddy Perkins was spotted in the
star-studded audience even hugging Emmy
winner Bill Hader Perkins an eccentric
character from the Atlanta episode aptly
titled Teddy Perkins quickly made a name
for himself after appearing in just one
episode this was due partly to Perkins
is sheer strangeness and partly to the
mystery of who exactly was playing him
seeing Perkins pop up again at the Emmys
was so unexpected that the moment was
instantly one of the night's big winners
worst the weird presentation format if
the 2018 Emmys format seemed a little
different than usual
that's because it was instead of having
presenters come out and banter for a
moment before presenting the nominees
and reading the winners name the 2018
nominees names came first followed by
the introduction of the presenters who
then bantered and read the winners name
it was a nice effort to break up the
expected order of things but it didn't
really work yeah best the live marriage
proposal director Glenn Weiss made sure
we'd never forget his 2018 Emmys moment
when he accepted the outstanding
directing for a variety special Emmy for
his work directing the 2018 Oscars Weiss
began his remarks by memorializing his
mother who passed away just two weeks
prior before shifting his focus to his
girlfriend Jan who is sitting in the
audience you wonder why I don't like to
call you my girlfriend because I want to
call you my wife to add an extra layer
of heartwarming joy to the surprise
proposal Weiss revealed that he'd gotten
permission from his father to use the
same ring his late mother had worn talk
about stealing the show Worst the
reparation Emmys sometimes good ideas
simply don't live up to their full
potential
case in point Michael J's reparation
Emmy segment in the pre-taped bit che
attempted to highlight the lack of
diversity in previous Emmy ceremonies by
presenting trophies to various black TV
stars unfortunately it all seemed
undercut by Jays apparent determination
to act like he didn't need to be there
add a nil time to Bill Cosby reference
and you have the recipe for a truly
lackluster segment spite its potential
to be both statement-making and
hilarious let's just say I stole it from
Bill Cosby best hannah gatsby steals the
show
Hannah Gatsby's Nanette was 20 18 s most
talked-about comedy special so it wasn't
exactly surprising when she walked out
on the Emmy stage to hand out the award
for outstanding directing in a Drama
Series unsurprisingly Gadsby sidestepped
the usual teleprompter driven speech and
delivered effortlessly funny jokes
poking fun at the response to her
special you know hash tag no Roman but a
lot of them the whole thing was
perfectly capped off when Stephen Daldry
won the award for his work on the crown
but wasn't in attendance leaving Gadsby
to accept on his behalf so I think I
just leave now and that's worst the
Americans brush with glory throughout
six seasons on FX spy drama the
Americans was a show that both critics
and devoted fans loved but it seemed
like the emmy simply never got it
however it's four nominations at the
2018 Emmys suggested a possible final
chance at glory for one of the best
shows of its era we had a job to do when
the show won for both outstanding
writing and outstanding actor fans of
the Americans were hopeful that Keri
Russell would win an Emmy for her
impressive work on the show however
Russell lost out to the equally
deserving Claire Foy the show's
outstanding drama lost a game of Thrones
was the final gut punch to fans and
critics who have rooted for the show for
years and proved that sometimes
popularity wins over substance
[Music]